les affaires tournent au ralenti pour
les chauffeurs de taxi de montréal en
raison de la pandémie se roide avait
l'habitude d'être d'une journée de fête
150 places même temps pour voir pour
faire 300 300 pièces ça c'est avec un
peu de chance
selon le président de l'association
haïtienne des chauffeurs de taxi sortir
travailler au début du confinement a
surtout voulu dire attendre les poches
presque vivre ils vont passer six sept
huit heures pour faire 15 20 caisses ce
n'est pas vivable
c'est très difficile c'est inquiétant
max louis rose albert venait à peine de
faire l'acquisition d'un nouveau
véhicule lorsqu'il a été forcé d'arrêter
de travailler en raison de son âge 74
ans ces deux coups de match où je peux
pas me mentir
la société d'assurance automobile du
québec et la compagnie de taxis à
laquelle il est affilié ont accepté de
suspendre temporairement ses paiements
tandis que son assureur automobile il a
offert un rabais sur sa prime si je
n'étais pas là pc on était tous bien
failli on peut même pas nourrir nos
enfants
à la mi avril la ville de montréal et le
bureau du taxi de montréal ont octroyé
deux cent soixante mille dollars à
l'industrie du taxi pour payer
l'installation de cloisons protectrice
d'une partie de la flotte et pour
l'achat de produits sanitaires des
chauffeurs qui ont récemment repris le
volant en pensant que la réouverture des
commerces des restaurants ou des bars
ramènerait les clients sont déçus on
travaille la porte comme ce fait du
bénévolat
si les charges de la voiture nous coûte
cher l'essence il faut il faut avoir des
masses il faut avoir des affaires des
gants il faut avoir les avaient tous
déjà fait à chaque fois qu'il ya des
sens il faut descendre fois les
désinfecter la voix scifo tous ses
appels à deux fois après une étape d un
client sait pas c'est pas vrai match à
la bcb plus c'est de la pauvreté totale
c'était aujourd'hui pour réchauffer le
taxer une autre épreuve dont il se
serait passé
ici valérie michaela bayne radio canada
mon frère